You leap out of a flying bus And are now soaring through the strangely-purple skyline above
a cartoonish island.
Your fingers clasped tightly around the handles of your hand-gilder — which is unironically
made of candy.
You’re dressed head-to-toe in superhero-esque armour — eyes glowing.
There’s also angels wings protruding from your back.
As the Tilted Towers rooftops get closer and you anticipate your first move, your head
swivels as you realize you’re surrounded by people who want to kill you!
John Wick to to the left, Tomato Head to the
right.
You’re breaking into a building through the roof your excavation tool of choice is
an odd combination of a plunger fused with a katana — trying to find some way to stay alive.
Your feet hit the floor and you quickly open a glimmering treasure chest in the hopes of
finding a weapon.
Welcome to Fortnite.
"I love fornite. I LOVE FORTNITE!"
Fortnite is taking the world by storm. But it didn’t happen overnight.
The game was locked away in development for almost seven years after it was announced
back in 2011.
The developer, Epic Games was working on a brand new game engine called “Unreal
Engine 4” in order to build a game to rival Minecraft.
"The community is incredible creativity has taken Minecraft into places we never could have imagined."
There are plenty of unforeseen difficulties associated with building a brand new game
engine, especially if you want it to rival one of the world’s most popular games.
And that — along with Epic’s desire to make Fortnite feel like a living organism
with constant updates and additions — slowed down its development in a big way.
Fortnite’s initial concept was simple.
You were going to get to build structures just like in Minecraft, but in Fortnite you’d
be building a base to stave off monsters called “husks” at night and survive the storm
for two in-game weeks.
It was going to be everything that was popular in 2011 squished together and blasted onto
your television screen from your console.
By 2014 Epic had a prototype version of the game ready for release and the Unreal Engine 4
was slowly being refined, but was held back to further smooth out the gameplay.
The vision Epic had for this player versus environment iteration of the game is pretty
similar to the “Save the World” version we see now.
"That kind of moment, that moment tha makes people cheer even if they're not playing is precisely what
Fortnite is about."
By June 2017, Fortnite was finally ready for the public, but the hype had died down significantly
since its initial announcement six years ago.
It was crisp, colorful, and combined the building assets of Minecraft with a shooter
like Halo or Gears of War — just like Epic wanted.
Guns, four-by-four structures and zombies…it had it all.
But the game more or less tripped on its way out of Tomato Town.
What was taking off though, was a different game format that players just couldn’t get
enough of — Battle Royale.
Battle Royale games were taking the gaming world by storm, but they began mostly as Minecraft
mods that were stylized around pop culture storylines like the Hunger Games by fans of both genres.
The format is simple: Contestants are all trapped in a remote location and must fight
one another by any means necessary until only one winner is left standing.
"And may the odds be ever in your favor."
The first non-mod Battle Royale game that had significant success was H1Z1.
This was the first Battle Royale brainchild from Brendan “PlayerUnknown” Green,
an Irish photographer and web designer turned battle royale developer, who had been working
on mods for a while.
He would then go on to create his own project — PlayerUnknown’s Battlegrounds.
"And then last year, Bluehole contacted me from Korea.
And said, "We love what you've done with the battle royale game. We'd like you to lead a team and
make your own battle royale. And PUBG was born out of that."
PUBG launched in early access during March of 2017 and it’s hard to overstate just
how groundbreaking it was.
Funnily enough, the game's developer Bluehole utilized Epic's Unreal Engine 4
in order to ensure the game could handle the studio's new 100 person bloodbath.,
Yes that same engine being used to build Fortnite.
PUBG averaged over 100,000 viewers at a time in both August and September of 2017 and even
attracted esports attention from the likes of ESL.
(Casting)
Battle Royale was in, and with 8 million copies sold that August and 10 million that September,
people couldn’t get enough of it.
(Stream)
So after an eternity in development Fortnite made its debut in the summer of 2017 as a bridesmaid,
while the bell of the ball, PUBG and Battle Royales had all eyes on it.
On September 26, 2017 Epic Games made a move to keep up with PUBG.
They simply put the world’s biggest game, into their game.
They gave Fortnite the biggest shot in the arm you could give a game in 2017
They added a Battle Royale Mode of their own.
PUBG may have been the first battle royale game to take off, but when Epic Games dropped
Fortnite’s Battle Royale mode, it became clear that the genre had yet to hit its ceiling.
Not only did Fortnite beat PUBG to console, but its Battle Royale mode was free to play
while PUBG’s cost 30$.
And unlike PUBG, Fortnite offered an irreverent, playful-style that appealed to gamers of all ages.
Battle Royale is inspired by an undoubtedly gruesome narrative.
But, Fortnite works hard to juxtapose the grim fate of that island with the kind of
bouncy, bubbly and bombastic gameplay you’d expect from a Disney Pixar movie.
After all, what could be more fun than wearing your bunny costume into battle.
(Stream)
According to Epic Games, Fortnite broke PUBG’s concurrent players record in February 2018,
hitting 3.4 million concurrents.
"And Amazon's Twitch saw its March traffic surge 40% thanks to Fortnite.
The most watched game in Twitch history."
The Battle Royale bubble has burst — and Fortnite has been crowned master of the genre,
at least for now.
Between April 22 and May 22 of 2018 Twitch viewers watched 139,333,216 hours of Fortnite.
And the game has quite literally become  a cultural phenomenon.
"What have you been playing?"
"Fortnite."
"Yeh."
"Did you get season four already?"
"Nah I didn't."
"Dang it you gotta download it."
"It's tight."
So needless to say, the relationship between Epic Games and PUBG developers Bluehole has
become a little awkward since Epic has now taken their Unreal Engine and built their
own Battle Royale game around it.
As a result, on May 29 PUBG filed a copyright violation lawsuit asking the court to decide
whether Fortnite was a copy of PUBG.
But, despite this looming lawsuit, Fortnite continues to leap into the mainstream like the
game just ate a hop-rock.
"It's all over social media, pretty much all my friends. You can literally walk on the street and see someone
playing on their phone. And everyone is talking about it."
"I know the game, I've heard references to it online.
People getting into trouple playing it too much.
Girlfriends and boyfriends you know."
"I've played once. And I got number 25 so I'm pretty proud of that. That's it."
"And I have this teacher who plays it and talks about it with my classmates.
When they play it and they talk about it over class. It's kind of annoying."
In game, what's most different about Fortnite
is its pace.
"It's a game, obviously number one: optimized."
"And that is why its popularity is just like *jet noises* a rocket." "I should try it."
"Yeah you'll love it."
When you die, you can get back in the queue within seconds and be right back in the action.
It offers normal gun fights.
Building fights that turn into editing fights.
(Stream)
And jetpack fights among others.
The only thing more limitless than the fun, is the capacity for skillful gameplay.
(Stream)
After its Battle Royale mode was released, it took Fortnite just three short months to
show comparable average Twitch viewership numbers to PUBG.
By February it had completely eclipsed its predecessor with an average of 97,904 viewers
to PUBG’s 64,654.
As of May, Fortnite has taken over Twitch and the game is averaging more than 178,000
viewers at any given time, completely dismantling its competition.
"You jump in, you get to experience the whole story for an episode, start to finish because it's a game.
And you get to feel like you're a part of something."
"I think that is massive for viewership."
"This is the League of Legends killer."
So what was the breaking point?
Well — it came in the form of a 26-year-old former Halo pro turned streamer.
On March 15 Tyler “Ninja” Blevins massacred the Twitch individual streaming record when
he played a Fortnite squads match with rappers Drake and Travis Scott and Pittsburgh Steelers
wide receiver Juju Smith-Schuster.
(Stream)
As soon as “The Boy Duddus” touched down on Fortnite island — the barrier to entry
to video games and streaming fell, and Fortnite became a household name.
"I think that that literal one match with Drake made it okay for everyone to play video games."
It’s not like gaming wasn’t big before — but in that moment — Fortnite became
mainstream  in a way that few games have.
"Fortnite is free to play."
"And accessible across consoles, PCs, and iOS mobile devices."
"It's the online game that has fans in a frenzy."
"Yeah I didn't start playing until Drake started playing so you can blame him on this one."
That night Ninja broke the Twitch viewership record with more than 630,000 concurrent viewers.
Just a few weeks later late in April, he broke his own record with Ninja Vegas,
his very own esports event.
(Casting)
The event peaked at around 679,000 concurrents.
"I can't even imagine what that looks like if you saw that many people in person."
"Terrifying, most likely."
After these two massive streaming splashes, Ninja’s stream took over the Twitch world.
As of May 23, 2018 Ninja was averaging more than 125,000 viewers every day while he streamed.
He finished April more popular on social media than the likes of Cristiano Ronaldo and Shaquille O’Neal.
Fortnite was vaulted into the living room-small-talk zeitgeist — and Ninja was right there with it.
So in a world of this:
This:
And this:
"Red Sox pitcher David Price said Thursday that video games are not the cause of his carpal tunnel
syndrome, but stressed he will not play the popular game Fortnite in the team's clubhouse again quote:
"to avoid the distraction it has already caused" end quote.
What's the next step for Fortnite?
Well, in a traditional sense it’s been esports.
Previous games that have splashed into relevancy have tried to strengthen their foothold on
the gaming community by branching their programming into competitive events.
Major esports organizations like Team SoloMid and FaZe Clan have already made big commitments
by signing players and building Fornite teams in a reaction to the game’s massive popularity.
(Stream)
In theory this incentivizes players to log hours and compete to make a career out of the game.
But Fortnite’s a little different.
The games aren’t the long, team-focused slogs that you’ll find in League of Legends or Dota 2.
They’re snappy and quick and it’s not like you can hold a camera over the top of the entire island.
Not to mention the logistical issues associated with putting 100 rigs and professionals in a room together.
But Fortnite and Epic Games are making a run at making esports a possibility.
On May 21, Epic announced that they would be putting up $100 million towards Fortnite
esports between 2018 and 2019.
(Stream)
Since then, during the Fortnite Pro-Am at E3, Epic also announced where that money would
be going — the Fortnite World Cup.
"Qualifying for the Fortnite world cup will be based on merit, and Epic will not be selling teams or franchises
and we won't allow third party leagues to do so either.
This event will spread that $100 million over a number of different online and LAN qualifying
events all over the world.
This will all culminate in the World Cup, for which details have not yet been announced for.
Before Fortnite even has a competitive game mode, they’re willing to come out and say
Fortnite is here to stay.
Just a day later, Epic announced Fortnite’s involvement in E3.
Where they hosted a $3,000,000 charity
pro-am at the gaming showcase featuring the
likes of: Ninja, Myth, Marshmallow and NBA star Paul George.
Ninja and Marshmallow were crowned champions at the Fortnite Pro-Am.
And as he raised his golden pickaxe with a peak viewership of 1.5 million watching online,
Ninja’s stranglehold as the “king of fortnite” tightened.
So Fortnite has built itself into this towering structure of commercial success and absolute fan obsession.
There are enemies on all sides, competing games and critics armed with boogey bombs
and pump shotguns.
There are in-game references showing up all over popular culture.
Your parents know what Fortnite is, your teacher spends their night chasing Victory Royales
and your social media feeds are flooded with highlights, memes and Fortnite players busting a move.
It wasn’t that long ago that we thought PUBG was the next big thing.
That the rest of our gaming lives would be spent on that post-apocalyptic wasteland.
Will Fortnite become the understudy just as quickly?
Or are we bound to that island?
Building ramps up to the sky, riding rockets to get that jaw-dropping kill and leaping
off that launch pad to avoid the storm and fly into Fortnite’s limitless future.